Cindy is with us in Nebraska hi Cindy
how are you great
thank you for taking my call Shirley
Anthony hey how are you I'm good my
boyfriend has recently taken a job that
requires travel and he's 90 days into it
and in the same field that he's been in
for the last three years and he took the
job because it's a lot more money he
doubled his income and currently we have
19 $800 a month lease between us and we
rent we don't have any bills we have a
car that's paid for
we have $20,000 for down payments or new
truck in our G and we have about fifteen
hundred dollars in our savings the
20,000 a separate savings there wanting
to purchase a new truck in an RV so we
can be together because of his travel
job he does have a per diem which is
$2,100 a month that he basically lives
off of in the motel with each gas that
pays for everything I mean it's able to
live that cheap and the houses that I
was 60 bricks that we ran in major thing
are monthly bills are about $1,800 a
month we're wondering if this is the
best solution for us financially just so
we can be together let me make them sure
out you said boyfriend five times I'll
make sure I'm real clear you're not
married right no we're not okay then you
don't need to buy anything together
nope no so who's got the money actually
he's actually the down payment is his
money I had my own business basically
it's his money but he calls it our money
because I don't care what he calls it
it's not our money yeah
no it's not I know that but I don't have
to pay any bills so this year asking
this question for him this is all his
money and yeah basically or not yes or
no yes sir
it's not a basic yes it is it is but we
consider everything art I don't care
what you consider the law doesn't yeah
yeah you know I if he loads up and takes
off and leaves you sitting there on the
side of the curb he's perfectly legal in
doing so myself no my point is is you
don't you don't combine stuff and start
acting like it
you know with your roommate you just
don't do that you know all right so now
once we've cleared that up then should
he do this no he should not you should
stay in a hotel okay can I ask why yeah
because the that RVs gonna go down in
value he's gonna lose $50,000 on it in
three years
absolutely yeah well you realize that
when you're understanding that well it
doesn't make sense financially it's a
bad financial move and Sydney listen to
what Dave and I are saying like going
back to the first part we want to be we
want to help protect you you know and
when I see boyfriend and girlfriend
combining in come together and combining
money someone eventually gets hurt in
the long run and so that's just not a
wise and smart move for you to combine
the income and then on the on his side
is no I mean just save up pay cash and
just travel if he wants an RV pay cash
for it but right now he doesn't need it
get their Drive their stay in a hotel
but their conversation y'all need to be
having it since y'all want to live
together and that like you married talk
about when are we gonna get married
people have to have that conversation
yeah it changes the equations
considerably when you do that yeah so
you know the other option would be to
buy $20,000 one because you got $20,000
that way you don't lose as much but
you're everything he puts into this is
gonna be worth zero
everything okay the truck it because
you're hauling an RV around these are
hard miles and road miles it's got a lot
of miles on it and it's gonna have miles
pulling an RV when people find that out
that thing is devalued quickly and RVs I
mean look them up look up what a new one
costs and look up what a ten-year old
one costs they're they're worth nothing
and so it's not a financial move it's a
move that if you have the money to buy
an expensive toy like that and you want
to do that then you've got the money I
got
friend it's got a million dollars saved
they bought $100,000 RV they're living
in their RV going place to place and
they're having a blast that's fine they
can afford to lose the hundred thousand
dollars they've got a million but you
can't afford to do that and you can't
call it financially wise it's a toy
that's going down in value and that's
our problem so hope that helps you